with many triangles good
okay thanks to the organizers for the
opportunity to talk here and uh said I
will talk about sparse random graphs for
a change and uh with many triangles so
what they mean and what I will talk
about will be clear but uh let me first
tell that when motivating the problem
I'll probably go over a few things for
the diverse audience so that which will
be somewhat basic to some of you but for
some of you hopefully it will explain
few things uh which will help understand
the results and the context
okay
so we will consider the simple random
graphs out of any random graph where
each Edge is present with probability p
and all our graphs are simple undirected
loopless graph on N viruses and we'll
always denote the number of vertices uh
no multiple agents
and each age is present with probability
Lambda Over N independently of each
other so the simplest setting possible
and some very well known facts to
probably all of you so is that
yeah
is that the number of edges is linear
and is approximately this quantity by
linear I mean linear in n
and
then
on an average the graph looks like a
tree what I mean by on an average you
pick an uniformly random vertex see it's
our neighborhood it looks like a tree on
with high probability
and it contains a small number of
triangles uh only a poisson that depends
on the Lambda itself so no n there
so these are the properties of this
graph which is somewhat well understood
by now and
then
these are mathematical properties right
and then some practical facts that we
see graphs in real life that are sparse
in the sense that that have uh in many
in linear number of viruses in linear
number of pages in them and uh
typically linear number of triangles in
them so
and not only that so it's not only that
they're the number of triangles are
large uh the number of vertices that are
part of some triangle is also large it's
not like only a few vertex con viruses
contain the large number of triangles
and the rest of the graph is like a tree
it's not like that so they are kind of
spread around
so these are not mathematical facts
these are observed facts so uh it is
probably safe to say that these facts
are not mathematically understood so uh
so this suggests that the networks that
are frequently observed in real life are
mathematically rare so
the question is can we still devise a
mathematical model uh to understand uh
this phenomena and to generally
understand this phenomena
so so now I will go into a very specific
model and tell you uh what that model
does and then we'll try to formulate uh
concrete questions in
oops
okay
so consider this model on Space of all
simple graphs on end nodes so it's a
probability measure on uh all such
graphs which puts Mass proportional to
this quantity exponential a n which is a
number that is bigger than zero depends
on N possibly depends on N beta is a
constant again assume bigger than zero
and uh if G is some function of the
graph so
to understand this measure what it does
when beta equal to 0 it's just uniform
measured on all graphs
when beta bigger than zero it favors the
configuration when F of G is higher
right so this measure will favor the
configuration so if you think of f as
the number of triangle then this measure
will favor the configuration where there
are more triangles so uh one would
expect or one would think that this will
do the job
and why one considered this why not a
polynomial say so
these are called exponential random
graph models I have not invented this uh
these are known in the literature for a
while so
and so a very vague explanation why
these models are considered by
statisticians so suppose uh we know the
normalizing constant how to normalize it
suppose so and then as someone tell you
with the magic that what that
normalizing constant is and that the
normalizing constant is differentiable
with respect to Beta then you can take a
derivative and see that you can compute
the moments of this FG when say if it
was a number of triangles and you can
compute them in exactly in terms of this
derivative of this function and a z and
beta so but then we don't have magic
wand so
but hopefully this clarifies why one
would like to think about this models
right
with false
okay so now uh we will slowly go into
concrete problems so how rare are the
networks uh that contain a large number
of triangles so uh here and always
whenever when I'm talking about networks
or graphs it's always I'm talking about
bar scrubs
and
how rare are the networks that contain a
large number of vertices that are part
of the triangle so these two are
different questions
so
uh we would like to understand the
networks that has large number of
triangles we'd like to understand
networks that have many vertices that
are part of the triangle
right and can we propose a suitable erdm
model to explain the discrepancy that is
observed between uh real life networks
and mathematical Networks
and uh we don't have a magic wand so can
we do at least some tricks uh to get uh
normalizing constant of such model if we
can propose one
so these are sort of the questions that
we'll be considering
questions comments
yeah so by large means growing with n
but typically we'll think about linear
number of triangles but our results go
beyond linear
both uh more and less yeah
other questions
then uh a formulation
so can we prove a sharp upper and lower
bounds of okay there should be a law log
of this quantity that probability a t is
the number of triangles in order
training graph G and P where p is Lambda
Over N can we prove sharp upper and
lower bounds of this quantity
and that's the first question and the
second question is suppose we can prove
one then can we say what is really
creating those triangles like there
could be many ways to put triangles in a
graph so uh what is responsible for
creation of large number of triangles so
suppose k n is n some constant times n
and we know that in order for any graph
this probability is very small when it's
sparse so when you put a a large k n
there can we explain this event
so these two are concrete questions that
we are going to now in this together
questions comments
then some more explanation about why
isn't uh did a classical ldq problem you
use uh rather than summer compute
exponential moments and try to get
something like this
so I guess this was explained a bit uh
yesterday as well so uh
so how we do uh it usually proven bound
on the at this very simple for
probabilities so
an upper tail off of IID sound just
exponentiate the sum assume that moment
generating function exists and right
like this uh use the independence here
and like within a few lines you get this
I don't want to like spend too much time
here
so but here that the fact that this was
sum of IID random variable help
we can write the number of triangles
times six as a sum as well
but there are peculiar dependence among
the terms
which
prohibits us from using this sort of
arguments
and then uh what is the state of the art
so we are again we are not the first one
seeing this problem so
so in last one decade or two decades
actually the problem got I think problem
has been investigated for 20 25 years
and last decade has seen enormous
improvements of
uh
but all in the range at this range when
p is between log n over n and uh one so
the problem so usually the upper and
lower bound that were obtained using the
classical concentration inequalities
were summarized in this paper the
infamous upper till
of triangle uh let's get some more
sorry
and
so when p is independent of n
that is the dense setting then this
problem was solved by Chatterjee and
faradam then the
variational problem was solved by
lubetsky and Zao so
and then
when tracking when trying to solve this
problem the theory of non-linear large
deviation started in so this was also a
non-linear large deviation
uh so uh this started the study of uh
this sort of quantities when we start a
piece parts
and it has a range uh which the P was in
the not in the dense range but P was
like a inverse so 1 over n to the power
1 over 42 or something so if I remember
correctly
so up to there you could push the P but
not beyond that
and uh so it got further developed so
when I say further developed in uh one
of this so in this paper the range of P
got slightly smaller and in this paper
actually a different problem eigenvel
problem was studied
so but all in sparse settings
finally this problem got settled in this
whole range by this uh
paper by Harold music and samotage
and
the related variational problem was
solved in this Luger's pizza again in
this paper so here they express the
problem in terms of a variational
problem just solve it here as well but
the problem was solved before in this
paper the variational problem
okay
and
and all of this if you know the range of
the speed they do not consider the range
where p is a constant Over N they're all
sort of somewhat not so sparsing of
sodium switching
questions comments
okay so now uh let us go into our first
main result and rough statement sort of
so
well p is Lambda over n and K N is going
to Infinity faster than log and Cube
I'll comment more on that later
and a constant a bigger than 0 which is
independent of n
then we can show that this thing happens
that log of probability the number of
triangles bigger than or equal to K N is
approximately this quantity
so
by looking at it anyone wants to guess
like what would be the cheapest way to
get this probability or what will be the
cheapest way to construct
this many triangles in the random graph
for the question is for those who
already don't know the answer
foreign
so this is basically just
planting a clique of PSI appropriate
sites
and when you plan the click of
appropriate size you get a lower bound
immediately and the lower bound is this
and this lower bound matches this
quantity and there is no more fancy math
so this is the lower bound so all the
works go into the upper bound
so uh the upper bound is difficult
so this is the cheapest way you need
this is the cheapest way
to
create
the appropriate number of triangles
and for the upper bound we basically
modified the arguments by Harold music
and some of these and uh we got this
result that when k n is bigger than I'm
growing faster than log n Cube
then this quantity is equal to this when
Epsilon n is the error term and we have
some degree of handle on the
oh
some degree of handle on the air term as
well but that is not top that is far
from optimal
but we do have some handle on director
and
and then when you have this quantity the
next question is okay so you have proved
using the answer that there is a click
somewhere and that the answer and some
more mathematics give you that
uh this is indeed the correct way but
then what is or how does the graph look
like when it has so many triangles so we
have some handle on that as well
so I'm giving you wrap statement because
making them precise means I introduce
more locations so
so all triangles so what we can prove
that when a graph contains a large
number of clicks then a large number of
uh triangles there is an appropriate
size Peak so all of them uh are
contained in a clique but we could not
show or we do not know whether it's
actually a clique but what what we could
show this is an almost big so what we
mean by almost big is a very dense
subgraph but as I mean many people in
combinatorics know that a very dense
subgraph uh might not contain a very
large click
so
but what we could show that uh
conditional on there are many triangles
there is a very dense subgraph what we
got called Almost click
but unfortunately this is the
disappointing result that so basically
everything is in a very small part of
the graph and you can throw it away and
then the graph is exactly the same as
the outer training graph so the local
limit
uh does not change it remains unaffected
even after conditioning by such a rare
event that there are so many triangles
so so the I mean what we believe is
Nightmare and still disappointing so
some new developments so as I said that
I'll comment on that uh a login queue so
after a couple of months after a result
so the upper tail so we were almost
interested in KN when KN was linear but
uh other people were interested in the
whole upper till so
uh the truth that our resin holds as
long as this Collision hold this means
that k n has to be bigger than uh login
Cube over log login so our result is
from login Cube but there they stop at n
to the power one tenth over low level
so
uh
so in this region uh
in this region uh our result holds the
similar
answer told and when this does not hold
then basically they showed that the
triangles are basically vertex this
joints so the poisson approximation
holds
so these are two regime and these two
regime completely described so the this
is the code from their paper the two
results together settle the long
standing up until problem for the number
of triangles in the case where the
average degree is constant so uh
any questions on this
you want me to elaborate
will these papers also consider the
regime where please between constant
number and to login over here
no no no that's a very good question so
that is considered in the PIP I think in
the paper by Harold moose and samothij
and then another follow-up paper by I
that paper definitely had Herald in it
but there are other two or three authors
that I forgot yeah but that is somehow
considered it's the
yeah it's performing in in some cases
and for the again when it gets a very
large number of triangles then they
cluster but I forgot the exact
ly
okay
then again it's nice to read a statement
like this but uh this is disappointing
in some sense so we get upper and lower
bound on this conditional on this we
know that this we are dealing with the
same artificial graph on an average but
we know that localization is happening
there is a peak somewhere that is taking
care of everything
and the graph is not only tree like this
is indistinguishable from our refraining
graph in the local weak sense
Okay so
so this motivates that we need to look
at somewhere else so can we inherently
disturb the local structure by uh
constructing appropriate events so this
motivates this following question that
uh can we look at the number of vertices
that are part of the triangle so if you
consider the number of vertices that are
part of the triangle is say n over 3
then you already disturb the structure
in the sense that you know that with
probability
0.3 uh the graph is not tree line so
so forget about our destiny graph the
graph is not even three like whenever
you condition on the fact that number of
vertices that are part of triangle uh is
are linear is linear
so
but in sparse random graph only a small
number of vertices are part of the
triangle
and if you condition on uh some event
then you know that it will not be three
like then the question is can we study
this event as well
okay so we can write this number of
vertices that are part of the triangle
like this
and we could hope to uh I mean one the
first starting point would be to use
existing Machinery so one could try to
go use the charity uh and demos
non-linear large deviations smoothness
condition but we could not check it on a
polynomial like this so this is
cumbersome
and then the second way would be to try
using some of each type argument but
that is a very different argument they
they basically focus on denser and
denser graphs and try to throw away uh
depending on so they try to increase the
viruses a bit and the ages in another
way but in such a way that the graph
remains dense but this is not the answer
that we'll look at so
we want to maximize the number of
vertices that are part of the triangle
we have to think about it in some
combinatorial way
and some new machineries has to be built
sorry just a very quick question I mean
previously when we considered triangles
we always consider the multiplicity here
why that the formula doesn't have so
this formula does not have a
multiplicity so there is no Multiplicity
ah yeah so you don't need to it's not
that we don't need it is not there
so just as
maybe I'm being your straight man here
but just as the uh cheapest way to have
a lot of triangles is to make it Clique
the cheapest way it seems to have many
vertices as part of a triangle is to
have a bunch of vertex just joint
triangles excellent that was my question
in the next slide yes oh okay sorry yeah
but but that's a little confusing as
well I guess the original motivation if
if it's to make things look more like
real Networks
Wells and forcing the triangles to be
vertic having
creating a pressure for the triangles to
not sure any vertices seems strange in
some ways we agree we agree with you and
that is why we were discussing Grandpa
Frank and Mark last last weekend last
couple of weeks like can is there a
better way to do this uh better model to
come up with we don't have any so we are
trying to see how far you can push the
exponential random graph in this case
and uh but as I said in the beginning
like I mean I think it's safe to say
that we don't understand how the
triangles created in social networks
yes
have you tried looking at in a random
intersection graphs so yes that is
another thing again that we were
discussing last time so they they are in
the limit uh
in the limit they are basically again
three likes or random intersection
graphs
uh
so
it gets created like this and
so the reason these are num these are
the vertices and these are auxiliary
vertices
and you saw one of this element wherever
there are ages you create a click
wherever there are edges you create a
click and in the limit how it behaves is
like a tree again but a click tree
so
uh they just
they just uh have an intersection of one
viruses
so which is again not what we usually
seen
so real world networker
random intersection graph has that
problem and then the random geometric
graph where basically the sufficient
statistics is the whole graph so in
viruses n data points and M size
sufficient 36 which is probably not
again yes
so the epion knowledge is like what they
call household models or maybe I think
you guys call it random Motif models or
something like that where I just
great sort of
distribution of small clicks with
external steps and then match the
external steps like in the configuration
models and you will
sort of sort of a configuration model on
clicks on top of Click so if you want
take a configuration model and randomly
replace the vertices by click so in your
sample example take the address linear
graph and whenever you have a degree 3
graph but places by a track
that would be probably the simplest
version
so every decrease three vertex becomes a
triangle otherwise you leave the square
facilities and what I do with the degree
5 vertex you leave some I just came up
with some way
I see I see so we were considering
another I mean that we can discuss
offline another model that Mark proposed
this might work
so the problem we have to always keep in
mind that we need distinguishability at
some level if you want to come back from
data to the model so going from model to
the data is one business and coming back
from the data to the model is another so
we need to preserve distinguishability
I'm not sure and maybe what is your
definition of distinguished business so
that uh you do okay so you need to
okay you need to estimate the graph
parameters right what from where you are
creating the uh oh I only have one
parameter P you take you build an errors
linear random graph and now every
decrease three vertex you are placed by
a triangle
and it would work that yeah
yeah that should be one explanation but
yeah we'll have to think more
good questions
other questions comes
so uh if not then
was this my next slide yes so again this
was our second main result that uh
roughly tells that when KN is growing
fast enough uh faster than login then uh
log of this quantity is approximately
this so if you don't want to really just
don't read it so uh this set this this
is the result
so
and again uh as answered uh what is the
idea here and uh idea is that the
triangles are vertex disjoint so you
create vertices joined triangles and uh
they are the cheapest way uh
to get uh
get the lower bound but the upper bound
is harder so for this we have to come we
have to come with a decomposition Lemma
uh which which is completely
combinatorial uh to basically we need
some sort of compactness when we do this
so we need to throw away the bad graphs
so how do we throw away the bad drugs is
through that decomposition Lemma but
I'll come to the decomposition level if
time permits and interest is there
okay
so yeah I more or less explained what I
uh wrote here so the calculating this
lower bound is easy you just sit down
you can compute it and the upper bound
is via that decomposition Lemma so let
me just go briefly into it
so
so
no random graph here so suppose the
number of vertices that are part of the
triangle of a graph G on N vertices is K
right and then make it basic so what I
mean by basic
delete all edges that are not
contributing to this event so if
deleting an age is not disturbing this
event delete that edge that is the basic
graph
so you've got G basic
and the decomposition is the following
first in a greedy manner take out all
the vertex disjoint triangles
when you are done with them at some
point you won't find any more vertex
this joint triangle then start taking
out
vertex disjoint edges and they have a
very particular structure that is they
will form a triangle with the first
layer all of them
and so on and there is a third layer
which is an independent set and there
are two things that can happen either
this will form a triangle
with an edge in the first layer
or they'll form a triangle
with an age that is going between first
and second layer right
and Suppose there are L1 viruses
in the first layer L2 vertices in the
second layer and L3 vertices in the
second third layer then you kind of get
a counting Lemma of how many graphs are
possible that are basic
and I hold on the number of their edges
so with that counting Lemma there is an
expression so that there I won't go
there is an ugly expression that you
would get and if you optimize over L1 L2
and L3 then you
see that L1 at the optimal is L1
contains almost all the vertices in
Triangle so this is the basic graph idea
of the proof
and this Lemma might be of independent
interest because this does not involve
any
probability or large deviation Machinery
rather just a decomposition of a graph
questions comments
good
okay
so
now as we started discussing that we
will come up with some sort of
exponential random graph model so trying
to maximize the number of triangle is
affecting only a tiny part of the graph
so we saw that it's ineffective although
it was long-standing open problem but
it's not solving the real problem
and maximize the number of values in
Triangle appears to be a better idea
although may not be a realistic better
idea but in terms of a model uh it can
give us something so this motivates the
following year Jim I guess you all could
guess what I'm going to propose that uh
we tilt so PG is the probability measure
of the sparse order training graph and
we tilt it by this quantity exponential
beta Times log n times uh vertices that
are part of the triangle
right and
I guess yeah
we are familiar with what it intuitively
means
any questions on the model
reminders why Peter login
very good question
so this is essentially n log n
right so when k n is n this is n log n
and
when we are proposing this model
actually this is fraction of viruses
that are part of the triangle and this
is n log n
that's why it is login so this is the
correct scaling
sorry it's login with parenthesis around
here yes login is that quantity here is
a parenthesis yeah
not vtg is not with a inside to log yeah
[Music]
so it model is clear right okay
so
we're considering this and we can as we
said that we don't have the normalizing
constant but the trick was to use uh
that large deviation result that we
showed and get this normalizing constant
using that large deviation that the
normalizing constant has an
approximation which is like this
and
we have a phase transition as well when
beta is I mean probably some of you can
see almost looking at the result that
when beta is less than one third the
fraction of values that are part of the
triangle converges to zero when beta
bigger than one third the fraction of uh
uh vertices that are part of the
triangles converges to one
yes so maybe you should take beta equal
to 1 3 plus Theta or 1 or something I'll
make slime
so
excellent so
okay so forthcoming result so which we
just saw that a beta uh when it is away
from one third this is not a good model
so we can take beta equal to one third
plus Theta over log n which is the
correct scaling and then we could show
that this converges to a quantity that
is strictly between 0 1 and as far as we
know this is the first exponential
regular study the exponential random
graph model which creates a linear
number of triangle and it is sparse but
as it has anomaly I'm not saying that
this is the best model but this is still
a model that creates uh that has
non-trivial structures
okay and what is or what are the
machineries for yes
so what are the machineries for this so
the
the decomposition Lemma we are saying it
is not uh I mean in terms of the error
it is not as bad as the structural
limits that we have in dense cases so we
could make it even finer by going a four
level decomposition and prove a result
like this where the second order is also
correct
so when we have that we could prove uh
such a reason
so yeah this is more technical but this
goes in the same line by
incorporating another levels in terms of
whether this vertex is connected to
uh two sides of one Edge in the first
layer or uh the one vertex is connected
to this there so we have if we decompose
in
four parts then we get an exact control
up to the second order
so you mentioned before that this that
many of the second players are most
trying projects disjoint most triangles
are vertex disjoint that result is not
there in our that paper but in this
paper that will be there yeah yeah
but you see I mean here so once we have
something of smaller order than the
first term we could prove that most
buttocks are most triangles are vertex
disjoint but it is not it is not I mean
we are not required to prove a finite
decomposition Lemma to get that result
so the final decomposition dilemma only
give you uh how good that approximation
is
just sort of
it is definitely not a tree
uh right so whether it is very different
from other training or not that's a
debatable question
so but even the support is different the
supports are completely destroyed
so part of any graphs button with limit
is completely supported on trees
you're right
but we don't do we know the local Greek
limited no no that is yeah and we are
not sure whether we'll be able to prove
that but that was the main thing that we
started but we are not there yet
looks like a tree but blown up uh sub
majority of the vertices have this blown
up triangle type thing
I'm just wondering because uh what Julia
Christian said is kind of usual Delta y
y delta type of transformation in
combinatorics usually the degree three
vertices is kind of why you can always
transpose into the Delta which is a
triangle
so we have some guesses or yeah or if
you have a larger degree vertices you
can always take two pairs of those and
put additional Edge by doing so you do
not touch the ETC density at all
and then I put the additional edges
between the cancer region and then you
add an edge but by doing this you don't
touch indeed overall Edge density but
then you increase the number of
triangles of course they they meet they
kiss at a common vertex of course
we're not sure whether we'll be able to
prove it or not so we have the guests
that you have the vertex with some
probabilities in a triangle so if it is
a triangle vertex it will have
additional some number of edges which
will come from the poisson distribution
and the other vertices that is not in a
triangle that will have another uh uh
another poisson number of uh children
and those children with some probability
are triangle vertex or non-trangle
vertex
foreign
[Music]
travels
that we know
okay so I guess more or less time to
summarize up before I see I put this
slide here
in literature so the primary use of this
models are uh in this paper by Holland
and uh Lionheart Frank and Strauss there
are many more sufficient statistics that
will developed in this paper and there
are hundreds if not thousands other
papers where they come up with new
sufficient statistics and the first two
uh theoretical results uh on the dance
regime are by mamidi bresteran Sai Sly
and then chatterjian Dacon is and again
there are more results on dense regime
by many authors and in this Parts region
the only result uh results uh that we
know of are by Mukherjee but that's uh
on the graph that a tree like so you can
consider for example uh two star R star
or combination of them and there you use
a contraction principle on a result by
both Caputo where where basically they
consider neighborhood large deviation of
neighborhood distribution of harder
training graph so but this results run
on a different scale than uh our results
so you cannot derive our result from
both the Navy and Caputo or Camp almost
done so
so uh so so we had to develop newer
machineries yeah
yeah so this is uh the conclusion that
our proposed model produces graphs that
are not locally tree-like and it they're
still sparse they have still some animal
models
okay summary uh we proved this result
and we showed that this is not I mean
mathematically nice but for our purpose
kind of useless and we proved this
result and uh the answer is that this at
least gives the triangles are spread out
somewhere
and a new uh eidm models with some
intriguing properties
okay
and some open questions so conditionally
on uh the triangles bigger than or equal
to K N can we do final results so this I
believe is a hard question so uh we
proved that it is a almost click so a
graph on say k vertices so forget about
our results a graph on K vertices but
our n viruses with uh say n yeah
and what is us with
one minus one over log n
times n choose two edges so n vertices
and this many edges but they are also if
we considered the external 200 graphs
they have a very small click so uh it
doesn't say that it is a clique it just
says it's a very dense sub graph so can
we prove final structural results like
it is indeed a
Clique or something similar we don't
know what to force maybe forcing
independent sets to be smaller but then
the arguments we know that it gets very
hard maybe quasi Randomness I don't know
how to use it so yeah this is probably
hard question
and so conditionally on this uh can you
determine the local weak limit of the
graph as we said that we have some
guesses and some advances but we don't
uh don't know what is the limit so are
there is there a simple argument to show
that the limit exists that would be nice
because then we can show that okay it
exists and we know that it is not a tree
like just by trivial arguments so uh uh
so these are another set of questions
and what about sorry what about
extending the results to other subgraphs
so for our viruses and triangles result
we believe that for cliques the
decomposition Lemma extends easily the
calculation becomes harder but the Lema
extends easily
so hopefully for clicks this will be
easy but for other sub graphs we are not
sure
yeah other than that questions
[Applause]
what about the first transition for a
giant component
so if you have
the local wiggling no no I yes I'm aware
of that but what if you didn't have so I
mean do you first need to solve the
local weak limit no of course not of
course not but
so maybe the exploration process
directly but wouldn't set more or less
gives you the local weak limit uh yes
but so if we are not interested on the
size just that our order n component or
just a transition
points yes where there is an order and
component then maybe we could use
instead so sometimes it will go down by
one about sometimes it will go down by
two so
maybe I'm not saying that it's easy but
maybe
yeah
only the giant component yeah
um I guess this is a really good
question but I I don't I'm not that
familiar with ergums so I maybe this is
obvious but
when you uh is the total number of edges
roughly the same as the uh the art of
shrine graph without the triangle term
or in other words
do the triangles get formed by stealing
edges as it were from the rest of the
graph or does it get those additional
edges in the typical case without having
to pay for them obviously
in the latter case then you would know
where the transition for the giant
component is and in the former case I
don't know
even
yeah
so uh when say when the vital system
triangle case like
they are they're found pretty
deterministically right like there is
dependent structure on them right so
when two gets created by another gets
created so it's not like you add the
edges independently right somewhere so
if you put them independently then it
will be easy easy to uh but we do know
that if you throw away all the triangles
triangles are at right so the typical
number of edges is the number of edges
in the base graph Theory graph plus plus
it doesn't tell you exactly what the
transition will be right because the
triangles will make you spread more
the other neighbors of all three corners
of that triangle
that makes it sound like the transition
should be around one-third or for uh I I
think it's going to depend on the number
of triangles
and the probability that it is a
triangle okay yes the sin under
branching process that yeah
foreign
so
um so you said several times about
realistic graphs so is the is there a
benchmark for that I mean is there a
data set or a graph which is
Mark sent me some data set last week I
was analyzing them but yeah
like so par vertex if you look at far
ages so if you look at bar ages number
of triangles they they are sometimes I
mean we have pretty differently like
sometimes part ages whenever one age has
okay let me explain
so whenever so for some graphs you have
one age and there are a huge number of
uh triangles incident to it but for some
graphs it is not the case
so so there was a yeah so there were two
networks uh at one of whom one of which
looks like this
and one of which look like this so the
triangles are spread more and in one the
triangles are really coming from small
clusters so it depends like which
networks you see but yeah I could not
decipher like other properties like what
to use there or what models would be
appropriate there yeah but just did some
basic uh analysis
suspicion
so this is not exactly your statistic
but just as a I guess proposal for
something slightly different which has
been proposed in the social science
literature maybe even some of the
references
sure yes yeah uh anything to do where
you characterize you know the let's say
I look at the number of pairs of
vertices with degree Z with Concord
degree 0 with code degree one code
degree two encode this as a distribution
or a vector and then and there are some
specific suggestions which we can
discuss after the talk yeah uh that
empirically that seems to do well as per
the literature
yes yes so that is a very good point so
I I've been thinking about this a bit
but I don't know how to prove large
deviation results unless you have a good
answer like
so if you have a guess about what the
event which will create the cheapest uh
thing then uh then the proofs are not
easy but doable but if you don't have so
suppose in the dance regime so
when you know what something looks like
random you know what we are talking
about it's quasi random so but here what
we mean by the triangles are spread over
so is there a notion of that uh instead
of thinking your lower argument the way
you're thinking about it maybe one can
again go back to Modern event Caputo and
think about you know this is a two
neighbor this this feature that I just
described only depends on the two
neighborhood of the graph so but anyway
law you know yes Cycles appear in large
numbers Caputo is out of the window but
because that right in that scale you
don't see any cycle in that scale you
see three yeah you'll never see you'll
never see that in Cycles
right right so you'll never get that I
see
but uh you know we should talk more yeah
yeah of course
yeah this is maybe rephrasing saurabh's
question
um what kind of graph are you actually
looking for because the one at the
beginning you weren't happy because they
were like it's like one Clique then sure
I've suggested one you weren't happy
about the random Indian section
Christian suggested another one you
weren't happy about that one either what
is it you're actually looking for I wish
I could answer so yeah it's not I mean
yeah if if we have a very clear Matrix I
guess when we can say that we are
exactly looking for this graph then
probably the answer will be there
somewhere what's the property that
you're looking triangles are not all in
cliques
the the somehow that if you look at
somehow Union or explorations of
triangles they're they're non-trivial
but they overlap so you have edges that
are in multiple triangles I mean this is
the type of features that you see in in
social networks
and none of the models that we know so
far actually produces this so the the
random sexual profit does not have this
behavior
and they touch generally at one point
but that's generally not what a social
network looks like
Police Department's been poor I thought
that was a very good decision okay
there are many triangles and they don't
just need to deliver things so so it's
somewhere in between these models that
all of these models are much extreme so
when looking for something in between
so this one still wouldn't work
there is kind of a three uniform
hypographs but then there is a so-called
high order connectedness which means
that in case of the the three three
uniform hypograph you can form a hyper
Edge as a triangle but then you make
connections only if there there if to
Triangle share an edge together
so for me it's like it's really from
hypograph
not exactly through uniform
typographically uniform Hydra or
simplistic complexities
where two Dimensions complexes which
arise from something else because you
really insist that there are many
overlaps along the edge along the
vertices
so in between I because it's kind of new
to me because I don't I don't usually
study something from real network but if
you look at the literature sometimes
they call like a
nested triangles
or nested
complex scenes whatever in Geometry you
know maybe you can Inspire yourself from
the properties and then they there are
also concepts of the collectibility it's
not hesitute of the collectibility by
the way but there might be some useful
Concepts from this discrete geometry
Because Of You the nature the triangles
are just
two cells you know right
it's important competency
and it's a zero cell one cell two cells
and I think you have a lot of this to
sell uh to sell sharing one one
particular shell cell sorry so so you're
saying that the vertices would be
completed Edge between two clicks can
tell you the size of The Clique that
they intersect for instance
there'd be a degree click size Edge
thickness distribution the cells have
its own degree support
see thanks for the questions and if
there are more questions
so thanks Moon again
[Applause]